payer quelques jours je vous parlais duo
paul reynaud de ce joli smartphone à
cette jolie boîte parce que le
smartphone c'est plutôt celui là aussi
vous en souvenez dans une vidéo de sucre
produit c'est le fait pour le comparer
avec celui là le réno de z
si vous vous rappelez de la vidéo je
vous ai effectivement les deux boîtes se
ressemblent beaucoup et ça crée un peu
la confusion d'ailleurs les smartphones
se ressemblent mais ils ont quand même
quelques points de différence alors le
but aujourd'hui c'est justement de
parler de se re et nos deux aides
l'aurait nos deux c'est déjà fait
d'ailleurs je t'invite à lire la vidéo
c'est pas déjà le cas ce matin qu est
très cool mais aujourd'hui focus sur le
réseau
[Musique]
et n'oubliez pas de voter pour les
smartphones de l'année 2019 c'est vous
qui choisissez quels sont les
smartphones de l'année 2019 dont
plusieurs catégories de familles le lien
une fois de plus en bas d'un description
d'autres et les résultats le 10 décembre
devant une assemblée de professionnels
qui se verront remettre vos prix dont
vous pouvez voter dès maintenant et en
plus il ya des cadeaux à gagner
donc vous pouvez y aller c'est juste en
bas n'a plus qu'à cliquer pour commencer
lorenzet regarder il est tout noté la
voilà tous les côtés si vous voulez
faire un arrêt sur image que ça vous
saurez tout sur ce soir après nous
aurait bien toutes les informations il
ya plein de choses à dire sur leur no2
end il ya beaucoup de différences avec
leurs lots de il ya beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de smartphones et des
fois on arrive un petit peu ce perdre à
savoir quels produits achetés qu'elle
produit intéressant qu'elle est à des
fortes hausses du cac et celui là et à
la fin bon on s'y perd franchement
et justement quand aux ponots sortie de
renault 2 on pouvait le dire alors au
final lequel est fait pour moi s leurs
lots de rs le réno deux aides il ya d'un
côté la différence du prix 499 349
mais qu'est-ce qui fait cette différence
de quoi est faite cette différence de
prix pourquoi aller sans regret no 2 au
lieu du réno de zèle jeu tout vous
expliquer première chose on va
s'installer juste derrière on soit focus
2 puis euros et on va déjà regarder
quelles sont les différences d'un
produit purement esthétique première
chose on va regarder si vous avez bien
travaillé si vous avez bien potassé 6
regardez la vidéo d'avant ne trichez pas
selon vous quel et les rênes au 2 quai
l'airé no2 l attention pop j'essaye de
l'écurie
on a donc deux produits le choix entre
le réno de leurs lots de z ça c'est le
choix 1 est-ce que c'est leur aide aux
deux ou accélérer nos deux aides choix 2
est ce que c'est les rênes aux 2 ou le n
o 2 aides ne trichait pas mettez la
pause marquée de moi directement ben
commentaire c'est parti bon maintenant
vous avez remis à lecture vous avez pas
tricher 1 j'espère bon dans des abris à
lecture on va regarder ça c'est
effectivement bien leur ai no 2 et celui
là c'est effectivement bien leurs lots
de z la différence d'ailleurs trouvé
bourreau dejagah la couleur mais pas que
la petite bille qui situe là où qu'ils
se situent là et vous avez une vraie
version ici regardez vraiment venir
zoomer et vous avez une inversion
c'est à dire que le plus gros capteur va
être situé là là il est situé en bas
s'est inversée sinon le flash elle est
exactement au même endroit il ya très
peu de différence mais elles sont quand
même là et vous avez une autre
différence c'est y en a un qui est plus
grand que notre leur aide aux accès
situé sur la gauche est plus grand
les rênes aux deux il ya une autre
différence si vous faites attention
c'est à dire que là vous avez les
raynaud de la leur et aux deux aides se
situe en bas niveau du menton vous avez
un plus grand montant sur leur no2 z que
sur lorenzo 2 une petite différence au
niveau de la connectique intérieure au
niveau de l'écran que vous permet de
tirer l'écran jusqu'en bas là ce n'est
pas le cas et ça ça change un petit peu
le prisme vous parlait déjà de tirer un
peu le prix vers le bas on a donc deux
produits qui sont quand même très très
très similaires qui sont vraiment très
proches qui ont quasiment le même design
qui se ressemblent vraiment en tout
point de tous les côtés mais qui
pourtant ont chacun leur propre adn
regardez lorsque vous avez activé la
caméra de cellfish qu'un homme qu'un
aileron de requin céderait no 2 est
celui qui a la caméra pop up c'est la
reno de zèle on a donc une différence
esthétique notre chaque modèle
mais ça ne s'arrête pas là et les
différences sont beaucoup plus profondes
mais le truc qu'il plus d'un et sont à
regarder juste après c'est du produit
l'appareil photo les smartphones sont
quasiment similaires surviennent aux
deux aides vous avez un capteur
d'empreintes digitales de la même
manière que sur leur no2 vous avez un
corning gorilla glass 5
à l'arrière un même sur deux soirées no
2 à la différence sur la bande vous avez
un corning gorilla glass 5 et non pas un
corning gorilla glass 6 vous avez
effectivement cette différence au niveau
du menton vous avez un écran de 6 points
5 pouces 2340 par 1080 pixels à 394
pixels par pouces un écran qui occupent
80 11,1 pour cent de la face avant
il est effectivement une petite
différence sur leur no2 vous avez un
écran de 2400 par 1080 pixels à 400
pixels par pouce qui occupent 93,1 % la
face avant mais ce soir renaud dehousse
raynaud z je trouve que les deux vont
plutôt bien marche plutôt bien
donc de ce point de vue là pour côté
purement multimédia ça fonctionne il
faut savoir vous avez exactement le même
haut parleur mono vous avez exactement
la méprise diack et lorsque vous
brancher un casque vous avez du dolby et
moscou avaient eu la haute résolution
ça marche vraiment bien les performances
ont pas mal avec un médiathèque p 90 mt
6779 8 gigas de ram 128 gia du stockage
ça fonctionne à savoir plus sur leurs
lots 2 vous n'avez pas sans étudier le
stockage mais 256 go de stockage déjà
croyez moi avec 128 ça fait le taf pour
la pure expérience de gaming ça marche
vraiment bien ici typiquement sur un
asphalte 9
il serait effectivement moins performant
que lors et nos deux mais il fera quand
même le taf
lorsque vous allez vouloir jouer à des
jeux pour les expériences multimédias de
lespwa faire tourner beaucoup de tête du
ps store et ça c'est vraiment hyper
agréable que ce soit dans l'arène o2
dans lequel nous deux est vous avez
exactement la même batterie 4000
milliards erreur de la recharge rapide
vous que 3.0 qui avoue de recharger 2-0
à 51% entre inconnus de sun color os 6.1
que ton sur l'android 9 paille ça fait
le job
c'est vraiment après une question de
goût personnel est ce qu'on aime color
os ou pas est-ce que la navigation ou
vous plaît ou pas ça c'est très
personnel
personnellement je vois plutôt bien il
ya aussi différence de score c'est en
tous sens rennes au dos et 250 9700
tandis que son créneau de zèle c212 1303
simple classe non loin du minho flight
aura maintenant une différence au niveau
de la photo vous à capteur principal de
48 mégapixels c'est la sodie mx 5 186
qui ouvre à f
1.7 qui cette fois ci la différence du
réno 2 n'a pas de stabilisation optique
vous avez un ultra grand-angle 8
mégapixels et ouvre à f 2.2 il est un
champ de vision 219 degrés est est ce
que seraient nos deux il a bien sûr
vision 216 degrés vous n'avez pas de
télé objectifs nous avons capteurs
monochrome de 2 mégapixels couvrait f
2.4 vous avez un capteur 2 mégapixels
pour le mode portrait pour les faits
évoqués tout va également à f 2.4 comme
je voulais montrer ici c'est une caméra
pop-up cette petite caméra pop up un
capteur 16 mégapixels tu ouvre à f 2.0
et lorsque vous le faites tomber elle
rentre dedans pour nous protéger
exactement la même manière son arrêt no
2 une des différences intéressant que
vous avez entre le réno deux aides et
les raynaud deux sections le réno de z
vous avez un zoom point x 2 x 5 et vous
venez ici aux points tandis que sandrine
aux deux et c'est là qu'ils aient une
différence logiciels saas et maro vous
avait autrefois un x 2 x 5 et vous avez
dû très grand-angle tandis que la lutte
racontant que vous ne l'avez pas là
l'ultra grand angle ici il vient se
cacher dans les paramètres justement
vous appuyer là et là vous avez votre
ultra-grand-angle c'est relativement
bizarre vous l'avez également de la même
manière en eau ici vous appuyez vous
avez votre ultra grand-angle
mais voyez en bas là vous avez foi là
vous avez bien l'école de l'ue traînent
en tongs c'est relativement bizarre
qu'on puisse pas l'avoir en appuyant là
ce qui fait que on a l'impression de ne
pas la boire alors que s'il faut passer
par le haut ça c'est une petite
différence logiciel rien diana vous
pouvez filmer bien évidemment jusqu en
4k à 30 fps vous avez une stabilisation
numérique
ici pas stabilisation optique lorsque
vous venez filmé avec votre smartphone
vous avez toujours les faits évoqués
vidéo toujours
application de montage se loupe et un
zoom numérique x 10 ici pas de zoom
numérique sans lui très grand-angle
prostate ou qui est vraiment très
intéressant c'est lorsque vous mettez
côte à côte les photos prises par le
haut pour red aux deux élus au port et
deux aides dans les mêmes conditions
exactement des conditions et bien c'est
quand même relativement différent même
si vous regardez la fiche technique même
si on part sur une saunier mx 5 186 avec
la belle ouverture est bien rendu n'est
pas le même
j'ai découvert sont plus terne avec
leurs lots de z avec leurs lots de il ya
plus de couleurs c'est légèrement plus
saturés aura quelque chose de naturel
mais c'est beaucoup plus qualitatif
d'une manière générale mais lorsque vous
les ondes et les couleurs sont meilleure
qualité avec leurs lots de qu'avec le
réno deux aides
lorsqu'on va sur le zoom x 5 on a omis
bride sur le réno deux qu'on a
uniquement en numérique sans créneau de
z est bien la qualité pas du tout la
belle en a qu'une chose qui est vraiment
pas terrible sur l'arène o2 est regrets
no 2 c'est assez naturel les couleurs
sont plutôt bonnes
le résultat soit saynètes s'enchaînent
aux aides c'est vraiment pas ça et
lorsque vous allez avec le zoom police
là par contre c'est vraiment gagner à
sortir c'est pas terrible
il peut faire défiler les photos jaunies
capteur principal sur une fois 2 3 5
3/10 principal soit 2 x 5 x 10 capteur
principal x 2 x 5 x 10 élus ultra grand
angle on sent vraiment la grosse
différence ici entre le au port et nos
deux lots port et nos deux aides ajouté
chamakh qui a été mis en avant par au
pot pour la photo de nuit c'est le mode
nuit totale l'idée c'est que vous promet
une photo dans une pièce où il ya pas de
lumière ou alors vraiment très très très
peu y avoir une exposition longue je
suis monté jusqu'à 40 secondes
d'exposition si vous commettez encore
une photo comme si vous aviez de la
lumière
alors vous n'avez pas joué déjà montré
dans mon test du porno 2g pas été très
emballé je trouvais pas que c'était
génial ça vous pas d'avoir un peu
lumière grâce une petite lumière orange
toroguhé avec le flash led
c'était pas dingo bien évidemment que le
au port lots de z qui est quand même de
qualité inférieure par rapport au port
et no2 et bien résultat est pas
complètement hauteur si vous comparez
les résultats entre d'un côté le haut
pour ino 2 et de l'autre côté le haut
pour nos deux aides et bien vous vous
arrivez à voir un petit peu quelque
chose avec le haut-pont raynaud 2 grâce
à ce petit flash tandis qu'avec le au
porno deux aides
vous avez toujours le petit flash peut
être qu'on voit la lumière orange est en
faible luminosité tout de suite ça
pardonne pas on va donc qu'avec ses 150
euros des cas il ya en fait un monde
entre ces deux produits c'est très drôle
parce que lorsque
regardez la fiche technique vous dites à
haut niveau la photo c'est sensiblement
la même chose en réalité pas du tout un
ensemble de choses qu'il faut prendre
pour avoir un résultat final je dirais
donc entre au port et nos deux élus au
port et nos deux aides
vous avez sensiblement le même design
vous avez sensiblement d'un écran vous
avez la même batterie vous avez le même
os mais la partie photo est différente
pas de tels objectifs pas stabilisation
optique des couleurs qui sont pas du
tout les mêmes
dès que vous arrivez sur le zoom x 5 la
qualité pas taillé forcément vous n'avez
pas téléobjectif donc c'est tout
numérique
en gros le réno de z c'est un raid au 2
qui va être plus là pour le côté
multimédia pour me dire regarder du
contenu pour avoir processeur qui est
suffisamment puissant sans les trop pour
la photo il est pas extraordinaire vous
avez quand même debout tous 5.0 vous
avez quand même dieu des smartphones de
bonne facture qui est intéressant avec
leurs lots 2 ha dont les donc sur la
partie multimédia sur le renaudot le
serais parti plus complète avec une
partie photo qui est vraiment améliorée
et qui est vraiment significativement au
dessus à l'hôtel soit vers nos deux
aides vous avez doublé la docile et en
plus une carte microsd ça c'est plutôt
cool dites moi ce que vous en pensez
comment vous le trouvez que ses
smartphones est y en a qui vous plaît
plus que l'autre raynaud 2 raynaud deux
aides qu'est ce que vous en pensez mais
moi je vous dis le modèle le plus
intéressant si vous pouvez l'être 150
euros de plus c'est le vrai no 2 le
réseau de z est pas mal si vous voulez
un grand écran sans cov et pour tous ce
qu'est la partie photo c'est pas là vous
êtes à titien dites moi ce que vous en
pensez en bas en commentaire quant à
nous on se retrouve dès demain pour
continuer à parler texto 12 en masse à
demain k o